So let's see what pipelining is about. So let's
say we have discovered oil somewhere very far away and
we have a gas station somewhere. And now we
take a bucket of oil, give it to somebody to
carry. Three days later, they are here and they
pour the bucket of oil here. Now we have a
quarter of a tank of oil. So we need
to do this about four times. It's going to take ten
days probably for us to have enough oil to fill the car. So clearly, the guy
with the bucket approach is not working well for us. What does work, you have
a long pipe and you start pumping some oil into the pipe. The front part of
the oil moves through the pipe. Takes it
several days to travel and after three days,
we get the bucket of oil here. So, what's the big deal? The latency is still
three days. The big deal is that after
we have filled the first bucket three days
after we send the oil, the second bucket of oil comes right after it. So, pretty
much, once we fill this pipeline with oil,
we pump some oil here, and we keep pumping
oil in and the oil keeps coming out. So
the rate at which oil is coming out is going to
be many buckets per day, although it takes three
days for the first bucket to get there. So the
idea of pipelining really is that although the latency
is long for one unit of oil to get there,
we can be having many units of oil in progress
so that when one comes out, we can very quickly
get the next one and the next one and so on. Pretty much we are not
moving buckets one at a time. There is
many, many buckets traveling at the same time.